now here's the thing this is why I call
this natural forms right this is having
an all could way to say it
and all the way to express this as this
it's true it's right but remember we
said it's different it's a new wave
function different in there but you okay
and also different in phase shifts right
now this is a really long way to push
sign to get into the right spot okay
it's plus so that means I'm going to the
left okay and you're going you know 7/8
the way around to get all the way back
to the actual graph if you want right so
really be able to move it over so it's
that way okay so how can we get it
looking more like this a nice small
angle what specifically and a cute one
Richard said Ian nice poem for you're
right that we have to minus something
but plan for weren't quite do it because
that'll be a different graph move Ian
pilot for will not make it a preferred
so we have to mean it's something which
what else could we move it hmm think
about what sign looks like the period of
sine is two pi right so therefore for
instance if you get some value of it
here okay this is kind of equivalence
what we're done it's really far over
right if I want an equal angle I just
have to come back with soup i right
because periodic so if I go back to PI
or four PI or whatever still be the same
answer
yeah sure in other way I can write this
is reduce
but I'll get it backwards supply okay
hmm let's study at me if this isn't
making sense shake your head at me if
you like what are you doing
okay I'm gonna stay with it for now
let's show another well okay all right
so Oscar I see we should run right sorry
I misunderstood what you meant
so when I evaluate this then I'm gonna
get it so 7 5 4 minus 2 pi okay now this
is a better way to write up is a much
better way to write it
amplitude is the same amplitude can't
actually be changed at all but I can
choose a different auxilary angle a
better one one which doesn't really mean
so far now I'm going to the right poem
for 45 degrees instead of going to the
left it's kind of like you know if I
want to turn right you could do a
Zoolander and turn left and you're all
the way around it's kind of I want to do
that okay I'll see you around all right
it's been up many years since I whatever
I'm not gonna get coming up in in the
details of Ben Stiller enemies anyway
you get the idea though right that movie
just a little bit to the right is better
than moving tons to the left okay sir
what you've got down here this is the
natural form for the exhilarating goal
another way of remembering it is it's
just what gives you in a Q value for
alpha okay in the same way when I had up
here this is also the natural form okay
but can you think of another one what
would be another way to write that one
there's an infinite number of ways
I could subtract you PI again right this
would also be equivalent to this right
that's another way to write it but it's
not as good this is a more efficient way
to write it
okay so let me show you this one more
way apart from shifting it across let's
go back to trig expansions okay then the
way each of the three expansions
okay now this is just reciting the
expansion's right but I want to draw
something important here when you have a
look at this first one right the client
of original wave functions right let's
say sine x + cos x that's what we
started with that was our first one the
reason why I know it naturally fits
better in this one is because look at
the signs positive or negative of the
coefficient you have here right
you've got positive positive right so
therefore I'm going to look at this one
this is the natural form because the
coefficients their signs
that's these ones positive positive
right it wouldn't make that much sense
to go from here to this because you've
got to turn positive positive into
positive negative in exactly the same
way but in Reverse when we dealt with
this question okay we should think we'll
look I'll go positive negative which
expansion will give me that more
effectively well this one right because
if I write it like this
what you can avoid is when I put my
coefficients out in the front and make
it really obvious okay if I use this
second extension here okay I'm gonna
have ah sorry cause
so do you see here now I don't have to
do that awkward plus negative one right
I can just say look this is one but
that's going to be one this is - that's
- so this is also going to one it just
transfer straight across okay now these
are the natural forms for sign there are
two more trig functions that we can use
right namely cause four plus and cause
for - okay so there are four natural
forms there's one - how do we actually
write it down if you see positive
coefficients okay let me put it in a
different tone if you see positive
coefficients like this okay so and be a
positive is impossible to me the one
that you go for is sine X plus alpha
okay that's the natural form if on the
other hand is - the - over here
translates to a - up here because when
it expands out the negatives are my
child together
okay now in what cases would you want to
use cosine mm remember what the cosine
theta station looks like if you take our
cause X plus alpha okay what you're
gonna get sorry just - who remembers the
expansion okay yeah good because this
one's mixed up right close it all
together so close goes first cos x cos
alpha and sine X so what would you
expect what kind of wave functions which
you expect lead you naturally to use
person well the first thing that I
noticed that's different is that here in
these expansions right sine is first and
then cosine is second right well here
cosine is first and sign a second it's
the X terms I'm interested in right so
therefore I'm gonna use it when causes
first sign is second and there's a minus
sign in between right so she
something like this a cos x minus B sine
X okay see this subtle difference
between these two okay
therefore what I'm gonna go for is our
cause all right no if I'm adding them
instead of taking the difference okay in
order to turn this matrix into a plus
because causes reversed right so I'm
gonna use this form make sense